not an empirical application but at
least I will talk about how to apply
these methods so the um the title of the
talk is separable matching seems to be
bizarre the title because if you match
people why do you want to do the reverse
and separate them but I'll explain what
that really
means and this is work in several papers
with Alfred G is
that so basically if you look back 20
years ago some of you were not even
born um the idea that was that
estimating matching models was really L
really hard taking them to the data so
one way is you just do Brute Force you
can always do that in statistic in
statistics iom matric you have a model
you can simulate it you do a lot of
simulations and then you compare them to
What You observe and you try to minimize
the distance between the two for
matching models it's not very convenient
and also it's not the modern Norm in
econometric which is when you get an
estimate you have to explain where it
comes from what are the hypothesis if
you just do this kind of Brute Force
thing you don't have a lot of ideas
about where it
comes um so another way which was not
used so much in statistics and
inometrics you just regress seem like
the number of matches between Highly
Educated people and not educated people
people and you redress it on various
characteristics you get estimates you
always get estimates from a linear
regression the problem is what do they
mean I'm going to show you an example
that shows that in general they don't
mean anything but there's been a lot of
this work being done in other social
sciences let's say uh so the new thing
is that it's become really easy to
estimate matching models and when I mean
really easy is that sometimes all you
have to do is run regressions but
Justified regressions or at least I will
try to justify them at least if you
focused on matching markets that have
transferable utility so this words also
for uh imperfectly transferable utility
but the whole talk is going to be about
perfectly transferable
utility and once you make an assumption
on the way an observe detergen which is
the econ econometrician term for Stu you
do not observe but that the agents
observe in the market when they make
their decision so just think of them as
error terms we have to restrict the form
that they take in the generation of
utilities and then you get things that
are really easy to do so how easy that's
a very good question uh so if you take
for instance the most popular
application of matching model with trans
perfectly transferable utility and the
iconic model is the Shar shic um beer
cman um model in which you have a
marriage market so the marriage Market
is fairly
specific um it's one to one so typically
we don't have polygamy or
polyandry um and traditionally at least
it was bti so there is one subpopulation
we call them men one subpopulation we
call them women we take one from each um
so in this kind of applications of the
pioneering paper in the empirical
literature is Joan s in 2006 so let me
introduce some
notation uh we have observed
characteristics of a man so a man is
them a woman is dou the observe
charactertics are going to be
discret understand but it's simpler here
to do it this way and for the woman
they're why and of course that does not
exol the least of characteristics that
matters to the partner I don't observe
hair color for instance usually but
probably hair color is important I don't
observe religion religion would be more
or less important in different Society
but these are the one that I observe as
the
econometrician and they observe more so
the true andion model says if you match
a man of characteristic X and a woman of
characteristic y so w as y m as eight
there is something that only depends on
their obser and I'm making it
linear and then there are these two
random terms so these two random terms
notice that they interact M and Y so the
unobserved characteristics potentially
on one side and the observed
characteristic on the other side same
here but what we don't have is the term
MW MW would be an interaction between
the unobserved characteristics on both
Sid and the you're going to see the
benefits of including it the costs are
obvious sometimes they might be
important if you look at data from India
for instance maybe it's really important
to have religion or cast which you may
not have in the
data um and the other reason is that we
don't really know how to model these
things they are unobserved to us so if
you put an epan MW orw you're going to
have to make a modeling decision it's
not clear which way you're going to go
so we start with that and in their model
uh these Epsilon Anda the IID they all
have the same distribution they type one
extreme values which just means you're
going to get formula that look like
exponential divided by some of
exponential so and the again we only
observe X Andy so all we can get from
the data is put people in cells X Andy
cells and count the number of marriages
within any cell okay so that's what we
have you could have data on transfers it
doesn't work so well for the marriage
market and so I'm I'm just going to
assume we have no additional data so
here what would you do Brute Force you
would pick values for the parameters you
want to um you want to estimate the
betas then you would draw Epsilon
Anda for everyone in the population then
you would solve for the optimal
assignment uh then you would agregate to
get this mu XY which depends on beta and
then you would compare with the observed
M XY and and that it's possible to do
and then you iterate of course until you
get a beta for which there these two the
one in four and the one in five are
really close so it does give estimates
that have good properties but it's
pretty laborious actually and also it
doesn't really tell you what generates
what drives
identification and what makes your
estimates
credible uh okay so the other three
directions would just do say I'm going
to take this number of matches between X
and Y
uh and I'm going to take a regression on
X and Y so I can always do that it's
being done a lot and then you do I don't
know if it's good English it's a it's a
French idiom that you you wet your
finger to see where the wing comes from
it's the thing I learned in the military
so that's basically the kind of
interpretation that you're do to do it's
not good okay so we don't really know
what the Cici mean so here here this is
how we are going to do it so the first
thing is that you have those new hat
they come from a sample from the
population so they have a sampling
variance it's easy to compute you know
things like mu MTI by 1 minus mu a bit
more
complicated then you use the uh Delta
method to compute the variance of twice
the logarithm and that's it so you just
going to take the matric of the
explanatory variable multiply by this
thing here oh it's inverse actually I'm
sorry it's
inverse uh then by five and then you
solve this linear system so this is just
a form of generalized Le Square so
that's how we estimate it couldn't get
much easier than that and in addition
when you do uh Le squares you minimizing
something so you can take the um the sum
of the squared residuals and the sum of
squared residuals give you a f test it's
a test of specification so if I didn't
get wrong so if the model is linear and
I got the right basis of explanatory
coar F I just have to take this thing
nor me by the same s star and I'm going
to get a k Square so very easy to
estimate and we get a specification test
in
addition okay and it's consistent it's
Sy totically normal all right so where
does that come from I'm going to start
to just take the simplest model again
perfectly transferable utility one to
one bipartite men and women getting
married or not getting married some
people could remain single okay all
right so then what do we have we have
the standard stability I should really
go fast on this so we have the standard
stability constraints that say that um
the sum of the equilibrium utilities
have to be at least equal to what they
would get by matching together so
fmw is generated within a match by both
the observe characteristics and the
unobserved characteristics interacting
and there's equality they do match
because utility is perfectly
transferable so they're doing to split
to divide the surface okay all right so
get this an equilibrium as we know uh
minimizes the sum of utilities that's
the duel and the multipliers are going
to be the 01 matching indicators
whether um M matches W and the
multipliers maximize the Primal problem
and the multipliers here are going to be
the and the V okay so we can use either
of
them but now we do econom so we need an
observe theity so just like CH and S did
we're going to say well the Surplus
comes partly from The observed
characteristics of this man and that
woman and then there's some Zeta
MW problem with ZW is we do not observe
it and all we're going to have is
whether these guys get end up being
matched or not and we're going to
observe the
characteristics so we know that even if
you take a one-sided discrict Choice
model you need strong assumptions or a
lot of data in order to identify it to
estimate it so here it's two-sided so it
gets a bit worse there Square the number
of cells and the number of matches so
it's more complicated and so we're going
to restrict this
Zeta and what we're going to do is
essentially what I've written before
with going to say okay there's a
function I don't know what it is it
depends on the obser characteristics and
then there is this one all the
characteristics of the man interacted
with only the observed characteristic of
the woman and then there is the
symmetric term but we are not allowing M
and W to interact conditional on The
observed variables so that doesn't mean
there's no matching on unobservables
there is matching on unobservables
because the men who tend to have a
higher within a particular age who tend
to have a higher taste for women with
the why are going to match with women
who within why tend to have a higher
test taste for the men of
charactertistics a so they're still
muching on on unobservables but we've
restricted it and the beauty about it is
all these results which are easy to
prove that said that basically you
reduce the dimensionality of the prod
problem so a man m is just going to want
to choose the observed characteristics
of their partner and so this become a
one-sided District Choice problem
there's the same for women of course I
don't know the U the capital u and the
capital V but they are much smaller
Dimension than the little um and the
Little W I may have you know 10,000 men
10,000 women that's 20,000
but if they're only in 10 groups I get
100 numbers 200 but uh there's equality
is there's so okay so once we have this
what do we do so we want to specify a
model so we're going to choose the
distribution for the epsilons again so
this is a man M and he has specific
shots you can interpret them in a
variety of ways with women of different
types who have zero as usual is not
being matched and then you can prove
that this five bar remember I have five
bar I have the epsilons I have Thea I
have chosen a distribution for Epsilon I
have chosen a distribution for AA all I
have to estimate is the F Bar
Matrix and so you get this closed form
formula uh I mean to Define things so
but the generalized entropy function is
essentially something that has to do
with the value of matching on
unobservables
and we called it the generalized entropy
because in the true and model it's
really the entropy it's the standard
entropy function in general it's a bit
more complicated so where does it come
from in a district Choice model the
first thing you want to do is take the
expectation of the mats you can get
which is just your utility in
equilibrium so if you have this uhy D
determine which we don't have yet this
is going to be the expectation of the
max it's a convex function because this
is linear this is convex and this is
linear so it's
convex so it and we know of course that
the probity of choosing one particular Y
which is here which is something we're
going to observe in the data it's just a
derivative of this
function now I don't know this so it
doesn't help me very much it said that
convex functions are invertible they are
invertible in the sense of convex
Duality so how do you realize this
miracle it's
multi-dimensional but you can oop sorry
you can take the LeAndre fenal transform
of G8 we know the Leal transform is
always a convex function and in this
case since it's the transform of a
convex function its own transform is the
function we started with which is also
nice because it helps us a lot and this
then is very important to us but because
it's telling us this gy function is the
transform of this function this
function once I know the distribution of
Epsilon because I postulated it I can
compute it so I can compute this
function I observe this in the data
they're just matching probability and so
I'm going to get the use I can do the
same with women and I'm going to get the
v's and because U plus v is equal to
five bar I'm going to be get a five bar
that is a sum of derivatives like this
and that's going to be my
generalized okay so this is something
like that there's a bit of notation but
it's really very simple so where do I
draw from here well suppose I want to
estimate the parameters of both things
the five bar which is the part of the
joint Surplus from a mar generated by
interaction between an obser sorry
between observable characteristics and I
also want to give myself a bit of
flexibility with the
distributions so I want to say epsilon
as a distribution that depends on some
parameters which I want to estimate and
I want to also let Ada have a
distribution that has some parameters
that I want to estimate so what we have
here is really a what's called in
statistics a midst
hypothesis a midst hypothesis just says
well there's something that's really
easy to estimate it's the matching
probabilities I know how many uh white
women with a college education married
with a white man with a PhD okay so I
know the MU and I'm especially
interested in the alpha and the beta but
they satisfy this equality so what I can
do is just take this so this holds for
every possible
cell and I can try to find the Alpha and
the beta that made this as close to
possible as zero as equal sorry and of
course there are disciplined ways of
doing this you want to you have a vector
of condition or matric of condition so
you want to weigh them in the
appropriate manner that's why had the S
star
originally so we get new hat from the
data and then we do this so that's a
minimum distance estimate that's General
formulation and you find beta and Alpha
now in addition if you choose the
weighting Norm
optimally so which is simple to do then
you can look at the value of over the
minimum so you minimizing the square
of the difference the weighted Square
for the right Norm of the differences
between F beta and minus the derivative
of the uh the generalized entropy for
Alpha and then when you get to the
minimum you are happy you have an
estimator of alpha you have an estimator
of beta but in addition the minimum I
said Lambda is just putting Alpha and
beta together the minimum is a Square
under the null
hypothesis of null
of that the model is well specified so
you can test the mod now if you look at
this this is still this one uh you can
make it linear yes much
l thank you um so you might want to
simplify this to make it linear that's
would be great right because if you
minimize a weighted Norm of this matric
and this is linear and Beta And this is
linear and Alpha then you're going to do
a form of Le squares just like we did
before in the true and S model the true
and S model my first example there's no
Alpha because we've said we have
standardized the distribution their type
one extreme Valu so there's no Alpha
parameter so this term is easy Alpha
here and I also put this to be linear so
that's one thing we can do it doesn't
come very naturally for models of how
the joint utility within a couple is
generated because if you look at a
couple you're going to say well they
choose their labor supplies they choose
their consumption and they you know they
take they do they use maybe some
household collected Choice model it's
not easy to generate something that's
linear in the parameters but you could
always say okay this is a sort of
flexible specification I'm going to put
reasonable basis function f little fxy
as I did before multiply by Beta then
once I have an estimator I can take a
stratal model of what happens within the
Caple and estimate the
nonlinear way to do it now this is a bit
hand waving as a justification for
linear linearity in
beta this one actually is much better
because the most common specification
you can think of they're actually linear
in Alpha if you take for instance
something like um type one ex Valu but
you allow the you allow it to be
heteroskedastic then this is going to be
linear in the standard errors that come
in the eastic specification if you take
your nested logic it's also going to
give you something linear so this is
pretty weak to get this linear which
really helps because if even if this is
not then uh you can maximize over Alpha
for a given beta and then you just have
to maximize
beta profiled
estimation okay all right so this I
already
said now uh again linear in Alpha means
you can minimize the weight in norm and
if it's linear in beta then you get what
I gave you before which
was LE Square so it couldn't really be
much
simpler and I mean it runs in I have a
python package if you want it and this
kind of thing runs in less than one
second much okay all right so there are
as I said uh you can apply these methods
to imperfectly transferable utility I
was not going to talk about that but
since I have a few minutes I'm going to
this is not me this is my coauthor alred
galish and Scott cers and Simon
vber and basically all you have to do is
you put an equation on the utility
possibility Frontier so instead of
saying the sum is constant you put sum
equation there then you use a distance
projection
argument and you're going to end up with
something that looks very much like what
I've done now one way in which you have
to be careful is if you start to say the
utility possibility Frontier does not
only depend on The observed
characteristics of the partners but also
a nonobserved characteristics then
that's going to be more difficult at a
minimum you don't want them to inter but
you can have for instance utility
possibility Frontiers that depend on h
and y
uh if you want to estimate them well
that's additional parameters it can be
done but you're going to need quite a
bit of
data so we can do many to one matching
like the Kelo craford uh model at least
we've done it with perfectly
transferable utility I haven't tried the
uh the other one uh you can do
multipartite matching like a rugby team
um soccer team I'm sorry there's World
Cup of rug the Rugby World Cup in Paris
at the
moment um so you can do so you can do
teams for instance teams in which people
have different roles you can do uni
partite matching so this is we've
decided not to call it roommate Jay and
chapl called it roommate but it sounds
really strange at present nobody
understands
why uh but unipartite matching is just
you don't have these two populations
separated at Sante and anyone in the
population can match anyone so that's
that's the easiest
extension continuous characteristics are
a bit more complicated because these
great model do not understand well did
you have a question no
sorry um so District Choice model do not
stand very easy to continuous Choice
model utilities go to infinity and so on
so you have to be a bit more specific
about what you want to do there is an
easy extension which is when you
continue to use these um
Goble um and you made them into the
proper kind of wome process so that
works okay and that's pretty much what I
wanted to do so if you're interested in
matching
with perfectly transferable utility or
imperfectly transferable utility I
recommend that you look at these methods
we've gone a pretty long way from
starting with you know it was really
difficult and now it's actually a very
easy task
to more and more application thank
you thank you very much there is a bit
of time while maybe sets up to ask a
question if anybody
has any question or comments everybody
is super
happy thank you again
[Applause]
the floor is yours thank you